bienvenue dans mon univers musical
lysandre où vous êtes une des musiciens
de la relève les plus en vue vous faites
de la poste
[Musique]
mais pour vous tout a commencé à l'âge
de 5 ans avec bourgade avec la musique
classique qui s'était par plaisir par
deux fois apaisé ah oui et puis j'ai
shalem un professeur de piano je voulais
commencer plus jeune pied vraiment on
disait qu'elle
a menées l'année prochaine puis j'ai des
frères et soeurs qui en fait du bien
aussi donc je les accompagnais je
voulais tester apparemment s'amener mois
vous êtes bardé de diplômes de la fête
des études à vincent d'indy au
conservatoire à l'université mcgill et
puis je peux ajouter aussi votre
maîtrise au royal academy of music de
londres dont faisait bien d'un classique
mais assez jeune avec le groupe de loups
10 vous vous en ligne et dans la pop
pourquoi la pop je pense que ça va c'est
une manière de balancer pour moi cette
espèce de rigidité puis de discipline
pour avoir une scène aussi où est ce que
il y avait plus de code ou est ce qu'il
y avait plus vraiment de règles ou est
ce que je faisais mes propres règles
aussi puis très un endroit où est ce que
je me sentais peut-être un peu plus
libre histoire
[Musique]
ça
votre premier album s'intitule sans
oublier vous parlez de la mémoire la
mémoire c'est important pour vous c'est
l'objet de votre thèse de maîtrise
justement vous avez une importante
commotion cérébrale en 2019 ou vous avez
justement vous craignez de perdre la
mémoire enjoint des morceaux de musique
classique assez complexe une crainte qui
vous habite s'appuie comment vous avez
vécu c'est justement parce que la
mémoire pour une mission c'est c'est
tout en feront beaucoup de choses puis
quand tu te retrouves dans un examen ou
est ce que tu sais même plus où ou tuer
parce que il ya comme 7,7
ce processus qui se passe quand où est
ce qu'on comprend plus rien c'est
extrêmement effrayant puis cela fait en
sorte que pendant un certain nombre de
temps je voulais plus monté sur scène du
tout et j'avais une trousse énorme de la
performance ce qu'on appelle de
l'enquêté de performance finalement avec
le temps ce que j'ai découvert en
faisant en étant est suivi par des
professionnels et donc de décrire là
dessus m'a aussi permis de passer au
travers puis de me dire que ben que
peut-être que c'était pas ma vocation
d'apprendre des concertos classique de
mémoire mais peut-être que je sais
capable d'apprendre plein d'autres
choses
mais bon ça c'était peut-être plus ce
qui m'était destinée finale
[Musique]
sur votre nouvel album il ya des fûts de
faced with your hands et de beats aux
versions sargent faire peur que je me
trompe non absolument pas est ajusté
comme
quasiment on voulait faire mon espèce de
dot de rappelle justement hôpitaux c'est
un espèce de
neige c'est un espèce de jude
contemporain où est-ce qu'ils ont
renversé complètement le narratif fut
même où est ce qu'on parle de la
sororité puis on élève les femmes qui si
on part de la chanson tout est âgé
et c'est sur cette chanson là vous
chantez aussi c'est le refrain toutes
les femmes sont drm ouais ça s'était
inspiré par la vague de dénonciations de
l'été 2020 ou vous composez vos chansons
comment justement aussi willy biteau
inspire la musique mais pour les paroles
comment la vague de dénonciations vous
inspirer mais c'est parce qu'entre
nous en tout cas on en sort on s'est
rendu compte qu'on avait des histoires
similaires puis d'en parler d'eux de se
confier d'avoir des témoignages
difficile à entendre ça fait en sorte
qu'il y avait comme un espèce de
tête un endroit très sécurisant ou est
ce que moi je me suis retrouvé puis
beaucoup de mes amis aussi puis j'ai eu
envie de faire un orateur finalement je
veux parler de votre disque vinyle parce
que vous avez une version vinyle de
votre nouvel album mutation
extraordinaire
non seulement il ya cette affiche avec
les paroles à l'ère du numérique on voit
rarement sur elle-même le disque de
couleurs êtes vous une passionnée de
vinyle oui quand même ouais j'ai reçu
les collections de mon père puis après
j'ai reçu d'autres collections de néo
classique depuis je collectionne à temps
perdu les mines il un peu âgé comme je
me montre ma petite collection
tranquillement
je pense que le geste des forains album
c'est tellement beaucoup de travail qui
sait encapsulé là dedans et donc ça
laisse des traces pour dire qu'en 2022
j'ai sorti et cet album sans oublier les
ordres j'ai bien hâte de voir aux
francos merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à
vous
[Musique]
et